hey youtubers is Charlie and we finally
officially learned the Star Wars seven
main cast JJ Abrams just released the
news so I'm gonna do a full breakdown to
that as well as address what's going on
with the story right now and what
they're doing with the expanded universe
they're basically kind of skipping over
a lot of that now that we know all these
awesome new things and we know that
they're actually working on script pages
we can start doing bonus videos going
forward so be sure to leave me
suggestions for future topics that you
want to talk about inside the Star Wars
universe and I'll try and dedicate like
a day during the week to just do Star
Wars stuff especially when agents of
shield goes away so be sure to subscribe
to get all that stuff if you're finding
me for the first time but let's start
with the big stuff so we know the main
cast members there's obviously gonna be
an army of creatures and extras that we
can talk about later but starting at the
top we have Mark Hamill Carrie Fisher
and Harrison Ford the Holy Trinity we
kind of already knew about them but
there were a lot of rumors as to how
they were going to be part of the story
essentially they're gonna be themselves
they're not gonna be hollow recordings
JJ Abrams actually released this picture
of a script breezed through they all did
yesterday we can all talk about that
script in a second but basically we have
old Luke old Han and old Leia then
there's Peter Mayhew Anthony Daniels and
Kenny Baker obviously in their original
roles you know it's not a party without
the originals so the really big news
though is the new cast members the
people that are playing new characters
inside the universe we don't know
officially who those characters are but
we do know who the actors are so I'll do
a future bonus video about characters
but starting at the top we have Andy
Serkis
who's probably playing a creature
hopefully a Dark Jedi creature that just
beep amazing Dominic Gleeson who was
Bill Weasley in the Harry Potter movies
I know Harry Potter fans would be really
excited about this atom driver who you
can see on HBO's girls Oscar Isaac who
has done a bunch of small stuff but
you've probably heard about him after
inside Llewyn Davis
then there's Max von Sydow who's
basically you know probably playing a
villain John boyega
who was in attack of the block which was
a totally awesome movie that you have to
watch and Daisy Ridley who's kind of an
unknown I'd be willing to bet good money
that those young cast members are all
Jedi characters essentially the big
teaser is you know will they be
Skywalker children from Luke and Leia
but here's where we need to talk about
the story because it's not gonna look
like in
thing we've seen in the expanded
universe so Disney made this big
announcement last week where they said
that to allow the writers of the new
movie trilogy maximum creative freedom
they're just gonna skip over the
expanding universe they're not getting
rid of it it's just going to be existing
by itself over here on the side like
alternate universe style so bad news
good news
you know bad news is there's a massive
roster of characters that will not be
used like Marv Jade and star killer but
they're not getting rid of anything so
you can just think of it like the Marvel
multiverse the good news is is that
chewy is not dead anymore and they have
the opportunity to sidestep any previous
issues with stories that didn't pan out
or they considered unsuccessful so if
there was something that you did not
like from the expanded universe you
don't have to worry about it I know
personally I wasn't a big fan of that
whole use of long story line I think one
of my future bonus videos will have to
be about all my favorite expanded
universe stories though there are a lot
of good ones and Timothy Zahn's heir to
the Empire trilogy essentially reignited
my passion for Star Wars in the 90s when
all they were doing at the time was
rerelease Yngwie HS tapes every two
years so let's all just take a moment
for all those characters and storylines
that Disney's Death Star just silenced
okay so onto filming so what's going on
with that essentially they've been
filming for a few months now but all
b-roll stuff nothing with the main
actors things basically that do not
require actors to speak you know it's
really funny the way big movies like
this get made did you know that they
actually start shooting scenes with the
main characters before the script is
even finished it's just so they can hit
their release date it used to almost
take you know like three to four years
to make a movie this big but now because
they compartmentalize everything they
can get them out in like two years no
one officially knows what the story of
episode seven is but we did see a
picture of an 80 80 foot on Tatooine we
also know a few broad facts about the
movie so here they are in no particular
order the new trilogy will exist inside
the George Lucas chronology you know the
Holy Trinity will basically be in their
60s pretty close to what their ages in
real life although you know Harrison
Ford is way older than Mark Hamill but
you get the idea because Luke was in his
mid 20s during Return of the Jedi we can
assume that episode 7 will pick up about
40 years after the events of the
original trilogy not including
flashbacks or any you know visions of
the future will also see most of the
major planets that we saw in the Lucas
you know including course on Tatooine
and Yavin they'll also be sticking to
George Lucas cannon which means the Sith
rule of two and because the new rebels
cartoon is also inside this new you know
cannon universe that they're developing
Disney has commissioned a bunch of new
novels that'll take place and fill the
gaps in time three of them are being
released this fall starting in November
the first one is about Grand Moff Tarkin
the second is called droids in distress
and that's a direct tie-in with the
rebels cartoon and the third one is also
another rebels cartoon tie and called
the inquisitors trap that rebels cartoon
is actually picking up five years before
the Battle of Yavin and I'm actually
going to be doing weekly videos for
whatever it starts airing which will
probably be in October so I'm gonna be
doing tons of Star Wars stuff this year
I'm super excited about all the new
stuff they're doing I'm trying to remain
optimistic about the new trilogy but be
sure to subscribe to get all my videos
and leave me suggestions for future
bonus videos I'll try to announce what
that you know Star Wars day is gonna be
you know during the week sometime soon
it'll either be like Mondays or Tuesdays
definitely Tuesdays after our agents of
shield goes away in a couple weeks so
right now click here to learn about
Captain America 3 and click here to
catch up on agents of shield Cobie
Smulders is actually coming back to the
show tonight so it's gonna be a lot of
fun thank you so much for watching I'll
see you tonight high fives
you